so um
welcome to my uh talk on constant
generics
so i wanted to start by saying a little
bit about me um my name is ethan braley
i'm an a-level student from england and
i've been running russ for around three
years
i've contributed a little to
constantinex itself
inside the compiler really working on to
cite
some of the error messages so sort of
like surface level stuff
but it's been interesting to follow the
feature in its development
so i want to cover in this quick talk
as the basics of the syntax basics for
congenerics
i want to talk about um why we need cost
generics to make
arrays easier to work with i want about
a couple of applications
of cost generics the limitations of what
we have now
and then a little bit about what we can
expect in the future
one thing that you may not have noticed
before or thought about um
is the uh the fact that arrays and rust
have always been cost generic um
they take the type for the thing that
they contain
and the and the number for the length of
the array
so here i have an example a array of
five strings
and we're passing in this five as a
const parameter into our array type
on the bottom two snippets i have um
arrays using a the more
general cost generic syntax rather than
the traditional array syntax
on this side i've defined a type alias
that shows the equivalence between the
two
so on the right i have um arrays using
the traditional array syntax
and on the left i've created this alias
using constant error x
so it's generic over t and our length n
the const n u size bit is bringing a
const variable into
scope um and i kind of like the term
cons variable because it seems like a
bit of an oxymoron
how can something be constant and
variable at the same time
and i think the way to think about that
is um the same way you think about type
parameters
they are um variable within the context
of generics
because we don't know what they're going
to be as but when we use them
everything's worked out as a concrete
value um
in the monomorphization stage in the
compiler so
our constants they're constant at a
point in the compiler but before then
when before they're worked out you can
think of them as variables so it's a
const variable
so one of the things that um cos
generics enables us to do
is to write code that works on arrays of
different lengths
so being generic over all different
sized arrays
and i i think this um begs the question
why do we want to use um arrays
why can't we just use vectors
because we know the size of arrays we
can simply push them onto the stack
we don't have to allocate memory in the
same way as we do with vectors
and allocation takes time so it has a
performance
performance cost and we can also use
arrays in places where we can't use
vectors
such as embedded systems where we don't
have a
traditional allocator
i took this graph from a blog post by
adam chalmers
and it just demonstrates how
switching an implementation that uses a
vector with one that uses an array
can yield performance gains
on the left hand side here i have a
snippet from
a old copy of the standard library
and it shows how the azref trait used to
be implemented for
arrays of different sizes
here where we're calling the macro with
pass
we're using a macro here and we're
calling the macro at the bottom of the
left side
and we're passing in the numbers 0 1 2 3
all the way up to 32.
those are all of the different size
arrays that we're trying to support with
this implementation
on the right hand side we have the same
thing but written with constant generics
as you can see on the impul we're being
generic over
t the value inside our array and n the
length of our array
i think this code is a lot cleaner and
nicer to look at than
the cumbersome macro code
it's quite hard to read it also produces
a lot
nicer documentation with rust stock and
it doesn't have that limitation of only
working for arrays
up to length 32. um i wanted to talk
about this
method coming to the standard library
it's currently um
currently unstable but with
what's been stabilized in the last rest
release
it will probably be stabilized some
point in the next few releases
um it's called a ray chunks and it's a
method on slicers
that so here we have a slice of
characters and we're breaking
it up into chunks of three characters
um i think what's particularly notable
here is that
our array trunks method we're not
passing in a constant parameter at all
it's being inferred by the compiler it
knows that we want a raise of length
three
because we're comparing it with a raise
of length three
so i think this um demonstrates how um
ergonomic um are apis can be with
console generics
and we can use cost generics without
really having to
interact with it that closely it sort of
can be invisible to us
in the last rust release um what was
stabilized was a feature called
minecon's generics
um which is sort of a minimum viable
product for constant lyrics
um a lot of things are turned off
because they have quite
complex implications that haven't really
been worked out yet um
you can't use anything other than
boolean khan integer types
in your const parameters and you
um you can't do complex you can't use a
conspirator in a complex expression
so we can't take like the length of our
array and then say add one to it
because that has complex implications
um but with the nightly compiler with
unstable rust
we can unlock a a few features um like
the full consequence feature constantly
validatable
connect constant eric's defaults and
some other features
that unlock a whole set of things that
um
that aren't possible with stable rust
with constant generics
so i wanted to talk about this example i
wrote
that uses some of those nightly features
here is a way of indexing on arrays that
makes
indexing out of bounds a compiler error
in the bottom left i have um
this if enum that takes a condition as a
const parameter
and implements the trait true if that
condition is true
that allows us to write this um where
clause in the impul above
that only implements the trait if the
index is less than the length
i don't really think this is nice code i
don't think it's idiomatic rust
i think this code is quite ugly but um
i think it demonstrates
some of the power you can get from um
from the unstable features um
there are proposals on how to do on how
this might be done without the if hack
um but um this it just demonstrates
right now what what could be possible
so i think the cost generics right now
is about make writing code that's
generic over a raise of different
lengths
um but i think the future is about
allowing us to write
more um safer faster
um and better abstractions that um
can assert more things that compile time
um
i don't think it's likely that the
average uh rust developer
will um will write much constant generic
code
but i think um what you'll find if
you're when you're writing rust
that you'll find that the um the
libraries and apis you use
will use costcu lyrics to give you
better abstractions